Good to see you.
Happy to be here.
I listened to your podcast with Jack.
Let's just get right into the jump in the Jack stuff.
Cause I listened to your podcast with Jack and I've found something very,
when I did my podcast with Jack,
first of all was not anticipating the blow back that I received.
It was stunning.
But,
um,
he what,
what I thought was I was just going to have a conversation with this guy.
Be Fun.
See what it's like to run this gigantic network that helps people communicate
you.
Okay,
Jimmy.
All right.
Helps people communicate and distribute information worldwide.
What does it like to start something like that up and have it become what it is?
Like how have you managed to try to keep up with it?
And what of the headaches been?
And apparently people online,
particularly the people that want to comment about this,
all they wanted to know about with censorship and that was an issue with me.
There was a question with me,
but it became a far,
it was a far bigger question for people online.
They felt like that I tossed him softball questions.
Um,
and that I didn't press him.
Yeah.
And then I listened to your podcast and a one thing about Jack is very smart
guy,
very nice guy,
but he talks in a very slow and methodical way.
And when you ask him a question,
he takes these routes and if you don't want to jump in and press him,
like you're in this weird situation where he's not totally answering your
question,
but he's talking about the same subject that you're talking to.
Like for instance,
you brought up Louis Farrakhan,
right?
Like,
how's Louis Farrakhan in good standing on the platform?
And someone like,
you know,
fill in the blank,
Milo Yiannopoulos or Laura Loomer or whoever it was,
they get kicked off.
He never got to that.
He went around and around and around with you.
And um,
he recognized this after the podcast.
Uh,
I received a lot of blow back.
He received a lot of blow back.
So I contacted him and he said he'd be more than happy to come back on again and
address all these things.
And I said,
okay,
what I'd like to do is address specific instances of people being censored.
And he said,
okay,
what I'll do is I'll bring in someone from the company that's in charge of that
stuff,
right?
So I'm starting to put together a picture of what it's like to be a CEO of
something as big.
And he's also a CEO of square.
He's runs the cash app.
There's a lot of stuff going on there,
right?
So He's obviously busy.
How much day to day involvement does he actually have and who gets censored in
why they get censored and how much is he willing to share about that?
So we're gonna find out in the next follow up podcast,
but I got accused of everything from being a shill to being a cock to being a,
and there's also an issue that you've managed to avoid wisely.
So of advertising the cash apps,
an advertiser on my podcast.
So because the cash apps and advertiser on my podcast,
right?
The man had you by the throat exactly how you think that and ask all those great
questions that were queued up.
The reality is,
those are the questions I would've asked.
Now that's hard to say because no one's gonna believe it.
But those are the questions I were asked and I tried not to be too
confrontational
with a guest,
but in hindsight I probably could have pressed more particularly on people like
Kathy Griffin.
I'm calling for doxing for the,
the kid with the Maggot hat on with the native American.
There was quite a few,
but I noticed that.
Well,
what was your experience like with it?
Yeah,
so it's interesting cause you and I have,
uh,
we had different interviews because they were time differently than me.
This,
it's an interesting topic because this opens the door to all the ways in which
our podcasts are different.
I mean,
they use stream live.
I sit on my podcast for at least a week.
So I mean,
in Jack's case it was like two weeks before I released it.
So,
um,
I did my interview with him before this flurry of interviews with him came out.
I mean there's a rolling stone interview.
There was a,
uh,
I think only I think maybe a Huffington post interview would come out,
but basically there was nothing out there.
So I had no real examples of how he dealt with these questions or how we talked.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
slow talking is not a problem for me cause I'm one of the great slow talker.
So we're,
we're in a groove there.
Um,
but he,
um,
I,
I didn't know what his boiler plate was and how he would,
he would answer any of these questions.
And,
uh,
your podcast came out before mine did,
but mine was,
mine was before the Covington in high school.
Catholic.
Oh,
circus happened.
Right.
So the,
the real missed opportunity for me was just a sheer matter of timing,
you know,
because the Covington thing puts such a fine point on everything that's wrong
with Twitter and the way journalism interacts with it.
Right.
And it was,
it just,
you know,
uh,
I think it was a Farhad Manjoo wrote an op Ed in the New York Times saying
Twitter is destroyed journalism and,
and,
and it was not a crazy op ed.
In fact,
uh,
after the Covington thing and the whole,
you and Kathy Griffin would've been the perfect example to talk about it,
but like what,
you know,
why is she still on if she's calling for the doc scene?
Right.
Yeah.
But you know,
I,
I think I had a substantially similar interview with him that you did,
uh,
because he's,
there's two things.
One is he is great at sort of pure wedding around th th th th the sharp pointed
question of,
you know,
what is the policy and why,
why are you applying it and this seemingly disparate way,
uh,
and it seems to skew politically in one direction all the time.
Right?
Uh,
but I think you also,
I mean,
you know,
I did and I think you did naturally,
we cut him some slack in that he's the CEO of these two corporations.
He can't be expected to actually know what happened in every one of these
microcases.
Like,
I think I brought up the case of,
I think her name is Megan Murphy.
I mean,
I hadn't even heard of her before.
The lesbian woman,
she's like a feminist who said sort of the wrong thing in the transgender space.
She said something like,
men are not women.
Right?
And she got banned and life or no,
I think it was temporary,
but you know,
so I raised it and you know,
he,
he obviously can't know exactly what happened in that case or at least it would
be surprising to me if he knew.
So the fact that he doesn't have his finger on each one of these cases and what
their,
what the rationale was,
and he has this sort of generic answer that what you're seeing,
you know,
in public is not necessarily what we're seeing.
In fact,
in virtually every actionable case is not what we're seeing in private with
respect to how these people are all opening,
opening multiple accounts and doing seemingly nefarious stuff behind the scenes.
Now,
whether that is true,
I don't know,
but I,
I mean,
I can just say that Jack seemed,
um,
one,
I,
I liked him and he seemed unusually open to talking about anything.
I wanted to talk about it.
So I saw one allegation they got a of you was that,
you know,
you must have been constrained by,
the topics you couldn't touch in advance.
He must've had some agreement with him in advance.
You know,
that didn't happen with me right now.
I should dress that there was no,
no discussion whatsoever about what was off limits.
Yeah,
no,
nothing.
And he asked her,
no.
So in my case,
I tell all my guests,
and this is the difference between use streaming live and,
and me not,
I tell all my guess.
Listen,
if at any point in this interview you put your foot in your mouth or I put my
foot in there,
we can edit it,
right?
Like we,
I want you,
I want you to be totally happy with what you say over the next two or three
hours.
Uh,
so if you have to take something again,
take it again and you know,
we'll just hide the seams as we go.
Now that virtually never happens.
Right.
And in Jack's case,
it,
there wasn't even a wrinkle like that.
So,
um,
but you know,
I just,
you know,
I,
I recognize it's a high wire act for a lot of these people,
especially for someone who's running two publicly traded companies.
Right.
And,
um,
you know,
it was the one I invited him on.
I said,
I said jacket,
we were DM and on Twitter and I said,
listen,
I promise I'm not going to make you smoke a blunt on video that got him.
So I don't know how you got him,
but I didn't try to get them to slow,
but I didn't even think about it.
Yeah.
We weren't drinking.
We were just talking.
Maybe it'd been better if we were drinking because it did seem very stiff.
Um,
I listened to it after the fact and
I mean I get from their anticipation why it would be disappointing.
I just thought it was kind of boring.
I thought my podcast with him just wasn't very good.
I sometimes do too many podcasts and when I sometimes do too many podcasts,
I think I run low on juice and I'm not as a,
I dunno,
I'm not as engaged or I'm not as fired up about it and maybe I just should have.
I've definitely should've prepared more for him.
But I really thought it was just going to be a conversation about what it's
like.
And I thought that would be really easy to do because it's such a unique
position to be running something like Twitter.
But he,
you know,
I don't know if he was evasive and because he didn't know the things or because
he didn't want to talk about the things,
but there was things like,
he didn't know exactly why Alex Jones was ultimately banned.
He didn't,
he couldn't recall or didn't know.
No.
Is that because he couldn't recall it was because he didn't want to talk about
it?
Or is it because he didn't remember it?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
you'd have to,
you'd have to be inside his head to get that answer.
Yeah.
Mean,
he,
he's clearly got a,
a very practice line that he uses to answer these questions.
And I mean,
cause I,
you know,
I know what it's like to have boiler plate now.
You know,
I've been a book on a book tour and you're just basically getting asked the same
questions again and again.
And here he's getting asked fairly pointed questions about,
you know,
where Twitter is going and he's got,
I don't think this is dishonest,
I just think,
but it has this amazing ability to close the door to further inquiry because he,
he gives you the full mia culpa right upfront.
You asked me like,
well,
what's,
what's the situation with,
you know,
the seemingly asymmetrical banding of people?
And he'll say,
you know,
yeah,
we really,
I mean,
we've got to get much better at communicating our process.
We're not nearly transparent enough.
This whole thing is in disarray and my job is to fix it,
right?
So it's like a global,
you know,
we're fucked up and we're going to get better,
I promise you,
right?
Yeah.
And there's do any good for the people that already banned.
Right?
But there's not a lot to get beyond that in an interview,
you know,
whether,
I don't think it's nefarious.
I think it could well be totally honest.
Uh,
but it does have,
this is a fact of you just keep reaching a certain kind of brick wall but you
didn't know was going to be there,
you know.
Yeah.
That's,
I,
I felt that too and I didn't,
didn't really match,
navigate that very well and that was a big part of the blow back.
But then the blow back was accentuated when they found out that he sponsors me.
Right.
Cause the cash APP is one of his businesses and its sponsors the podcast.
Yeah.
Well I had a very similar result and I don't have that,
that problem.
So you know,
that I don't think that diagnosis your situation at all.
But it's very,
I mean the difference between these business,
the business models under which we run our podcasts and um,
just the different,
I mean,
just every choice you make and how to produce a podcast.
I essentially have made the opposite one.
You know,
there's like streaming live like this,
the fact that you're,
so,
this is just all very interesting to me.
I'm kind of a reluctant student of digital media now because I've just kind of
stumbled into this wild west that,
you know,
you in large part have invented,
right?
I mean this podcasting space was nothing.
And now we've got Spotify,
you know,
buying up and it says he's like a land grab for audio.
Yeah,
the,
we were talking about that before the podcast.
They just purchased some company.
What does it,
what is it called?
Kevin went for some godly amount of money.
Yeah.
Like $200 million.
They're going to spend 500 this year or something.
And so it's,
it's this w we're all just making this up and you know,
I'm making,
and you know,
I've just released a meditation APP,
which is a different business model still.
And so now I have these kind of two parallel digital businesses happening in my
life and it's,
um,
it's just very interesting.
The decisions you make are a force to make and the consequences of it.
And so like the fact that we're having this conversation live,
you don't even have to think about whether you're going to edit this,
right?
Cause it's gonna be streaming live.
And you know,
we're going to,
when we're done,
we're going to turn off the mics and walk out of here and your job is done with
my podcast.
That's not the workflow at all.
And I,
so I,
I totally envy this,
this approach that you have,
but for a variety of reasons,
I feel like I can't take it in,
in my life.
And so it's,
it's,
uh,
but it is very different and it dictates many choices,
you know,
down the line,
which,
um,
uh,
I mean there's,
there's a positive and negative,
but it's,
you know,
the,
the positive is what you hear is what we got and we're done after we turn these
mikes off.
And that's,
and that's not,
you know,
that's not how I podcast.
There's also the visual element of it and the visual element of it.
And initially it was almost like a side effect.
I mean we,
we first started it out visually,
but then when it started going to iTunes,
the iTunes aspect of it became the focus.
The uh,
audio version of it rather became the focus.
But then we decided to stream on Youtube and put it up on Youtube.
But it was totally not profitable.
It was just for,
for a goof like,
oh,
we'll have the video up.
Why not?
Some people like video.
It was one of those things.
But then you realize ultimately that youtube becomes a viable source of revenue.
And then it's also the way a lot of people like to watch it,
you know?
And they also like to watch it because they can comment under it.
So that was the other thing that came out of the Jack podcast.
We got into a controversy about comments and about how comments are deleted or
how they sh they're shown in hidden and what happens cause people were accusing
Jamie of deleting all the derogatory comments that we don't touch any,
we don't,
we don't delete any of them.
We don't do anything to them.
We just leave them up there.
And it's a mostly a cesspool,
but I mean,
even even on a good podcast,
there's a lot of crazy shit that happens on these things.
But from what we think,
and Jamie correct me if I'm wrong,
you think that what's going on is that people are marking other people's posts
as spam.
Yeah.
There's that.
And then Brandon also has a theory that a lot of alt right people are targeted
by the algorithm that youtube uses.
Like in,
in,
in one case,
there was a guy who had a pepe,
the frog Avatar,
and he said like his,
his comment immediately went to spam and that the other thing is that the
comments are curated depending upon who is watching it and what account it will
be.
There'll be different sort of,
yeah.
The,
they'll propagate different comments to the top.
It's not a this,
you can actually change it if you,
if you prefer to see the most new comment,
like from your own personal youtube when you're watching you,
you as a viewer or user of Youtube half to make that actual,
yeah.
So that,
that conspiracy theory just heightened the whole thing.
Right.
Okay.
Now they're deleting negative comments like,
look,
I don't like doing bad podcast,
but I will be the first one to tell you when I think a podcast sucked.
That was definitely disappointing.
It wasn't good.
Mine wasn't good.
It was,
like I said,
when I listened to it,
I was like,
God,
this is kind of boring.
It just wasn't,
it wasn't juicy.
There was nothing,
we didn't get a flow.
It wasn't like he and I were just shooting the shit
time.
What's it take that one decision.
So you have decided to make video a main component of this podcast know it's
still probably a small percentage of your actual listens.
You're not anymore.
Not Anymore.
It's,
it's gotten to,
well it's almost 50 50 oh,
awesome.
Closing in on that.
It used to be like 90 10 right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So I have it.
I don't have a video component and so I just put audio on Youtube,
but I put absolutely no energy and to youtube.
I mean that may one day change,
but because I don't,
I don't care what's happening on Youtube.
Right.
So I never see the comments.
And whenever I look,
it is,
as you say,
assessable,
it's insane.
I mean,
youtube is just skews massively,
right?
It's skews,
you know,
just a massively mail and it's probably skews very young too.
So you have it just like millennial alt-right craziness.
Right?
Like,
like as I say these sentences,
your youtube page or just blowing up with hate for me,
you've got a bunch of millennials with a thumbs up their acids,
just when Jane.
Right.
You know,
this'll be older people too.
Well,
yeah.
But I mean it's gotta be younger than,
than most of,
of where,
well,
first of all,
I'm not even seeing most common threads that could possibly respond to anything
I put out there now.
Right.
So I got a,
I don't even look at my app mentions for the most part,
I spend maybe five minutes a day looking at that's healthy,
but it's coming back to me and [inaudible] were actually helpful and,
and reformat in my brain on that,
on that topic.
But,
um,
so because I don't see any of that stuff,
I mean maybe I'm getting a lot of pain for my Dorsey interview,
but I don't even know about it.
Right.
And so I'm not having,
I don't feel like I have to course correct in response to anything now and in
large measure it is a consequence of just this decision that,
you know,
I inadvertently made that I'm just,
I don't have a video component to my podcast at the moment.
And so I'm not,
I'm not spectating on the,
you know,
the feedback on Youtube.
Well the feedback thing is interesting because what we're just talking about
this before the show that with feedback and comments on youtube,
essentially anyone can comment and if you don't go banning people from the
channel,
which we don't do,
it's not what we wouldn't do.
Someone was totally a piece of shit,
but we don't.
So you essentially have this open forum.
So it's like almost like a message board where people would be just sort of
comment and it's unlike Twitter in that regard because Twitter just,
you know,
you get abusive and Shitty on Twitter.
They just get rid of you.
If you get abusive in Shitty on Instagram or on Facebook,
Facebook,
they'll just get rid of you.
But if you're on youtube and you're in those comments,
you could kind of get away with more.
So I would imagine that people that don't appreciate censorship and want to just
just fucking spew out whatever's on their mind,
that would be the place that they would go,
especially if it's the same product.
Essentially.
The only thing different,
and this is a thing where it got confusing with the youtube people versus the
audio people with the audio people,
it's very obvious that the cash app has a sponsor because it's,
we say it,
this podcast is brought to you by the cash app,
whereas in Youtube they're like,
aw,
they're hiding the fact that the cash apps a sponsor,
right.
We talked about it during the podcast itself,
but we don't put the ads on Youtube.
We,
there's ads that youtube puts on,
but we put the ads on like after the show is over,
I'll read the ads and we'll insert those into the audio and that will go up to
iTunes and RSS feeds and all that stuff.
So the stuff that's on youtube,
it's abbreviated in the sense that especially the live one doesn't have
anything.
So like this has zero ads and then the ones that will be posted on youtube
later,
a little have youtube ads.
Right.
So that's why there's,
so there was a couple of conspiracy theories in that regard.
There's also apparently an emerging conspiracy theory about that Jack was trying
to pump up bitcoin because they have some sort of a bit coin deal.
Have you heard this one?
I read that,
but like it's,
from what I saw,
it's not higher than it was at any point.
It's still right around $3,500.
So if there was a pump and dump scheme of some sort,
then like it should be shooting like provable on a blockchain,
I guess.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
I don't understand that.
But is there any other component to it?
I don't know.
I don't know where that was coming from.
This,
I don't even know what did it.
All he said was that,
well,
the cash APP sells bitcoins.
So we talked about Bitcoin,
I think because you can buy and sell bitcoin through the cash app,
I should say.
I think he said something about blockchain technology,
rendering everything permanent online,
and that was,
that was something different though.
Yeah,
but that,
that,
I think that's in regard to comments into anything.
Blog posts,
blockchain is essentially going to have everything that's online forever,
but there's so many fucking conspiracy theories about all this stuff.
It's,
it's fascinating.